all right as we continue tonight
reporting from Washington D.C the swamp
as I've been saying House Republicans
now unified behind an agenda to hold the
Biden Administration accountable on
everything from the border to the
origins of covid the FBI are they
politicized is the doj weaponized and we
continue now with the new Speaker of the
House Kevin McCarthy along with House
Majority Leader Steve scalise joins us
and house Republican conference chair
Elise stefanik good to see you all uh yo
you guys all happy with your leadership
now
respect
if not I was thinking you could always
hold another Vote or two uh I think I've
had enough you've had enough
um
we've known each other for a long time
Steve and
this is to me a pivotal moment for the
country I know for example I do three
hours of radio every day and I hear from
my audience every day and they are
genuinely frightened about the economy
about energy about open borders all the
things that is on that paper that Kevin
has how how realistic is it that we can
get all of this done well Sean I think
it's so important that the American
people finally said enough is enough and
look there is a lot of Despair out there
families are struggling and the real
problem was they did not see Washington
working for them because Washington was
working against them the problems
families are facing from higher costs
inflation high energy costs open border
all created by President Biden the
extreme agenda of Nancy Pelosi and Chuck
Schumer and so people said okay we've
got one opportunity to at least put some
checks and balances and send people
willing to fight for the families that
are left behind and that was really at
the heart of the rules package because
before we can go start fighting for
those families we had to change the way
Washington worked and that's really why
the Democrats were so concerned about
these rules changes because they
realized the party's over the idea that
you can write four or five thousand page
bills by dark of night the old Pelosi
way of you got to pass the bill to find
out what's in it those days are over so
that's 72-hour rule is Rockstar 72-hour
rule single subject bills Sean allowing
members all members not just in
leadership but Rank and file members to
be engaged in the process of going to
bat for those families who are
struggling and add amendments during the
Appropriations process yeah that hasn't
happened you know you know what's the
difference now this is probably more
people in the public that's ever been in
the Capitol in the last two years we've
now opened the doors I want to invite
everyone who's listening if you've ever
dreamed of coming to DC come to DC and
you know what you can sit in the gallery
and you can watch us debate you can see
your government at work because this is
your house this is your government and
we have just now empowered you even
greater than ever before so that brings
accountability just to start out with
and we want you to join with us no
matter what party you're in but if you
believe in securing your border if you
believe that you want to be able to fill
up your tank but have money left over
for food you want to be energy
independent you see the story out of
your state of California the notice they
sent out to expect your energy bill to
double from where last year because what
Gavin Newsom has done to California he
has shrunk our grid and then he tells
you can only buy electric car then you
can't charge it it is you can only
charge it between certain hours
but you'll pay 40 you'll pay 40 higher
yeah there's a reason why for the first
time in the history of California we're
decreasing the people are leaving it's
their Democratic policies that they have
tried to put here in Washington and
fortunately when the American public
spoke here to Congress you now have a
voice you have a check and balance and
we will stand up and that's our
commitment you know uh congresswoman I
know I've known you a long time
um one of the things I'd like to see and
I'm seeing is more diversity in the
Republican party to me the Democratic
party is the party of coastal Elites
it'll they're not representing the men
and women that make this country run and
work every day to me and I see the
America First agenda why I like it so
much is it really appeals to all the
people in this country that get up every
day work hard play by the rule schools
pay their taxes obey the laws and raise
their kids and don't want their values
contradicted by some teacher with an
agenda and all of that is now on paper
written down how confident are you that
all of this will get accomplished well
I'm so confident take a look around at
these wonderful members this is the most
diverse class of Republicans ever
elected in the history of the United
States Congress we have more women than
were ever elected before more Hispanic
members ever elected before more
African-American members in modern
history this shows that our party is
growing and I will tell you the America
First agenda is a growing big tent
agenda we've never done better than we
do today among Hispanic voters and
president Trump and House Republicans
were a huge part of doing that and
what's most important is the American
people are going to judge us by the
results we've delivered look at this
past week we're already keeping our
promises on day one we repealed the 87
000 IRS agents we just set up by the way
most of them had a Target on my back so
go ahead
those agents were targeting hard-working
Americans
report today absolutely hard-working
Americans like I represent in Upstate
New York so we are making good on our
agenda and we are going to go through
that commitment to America to show the
American people what House Republicans
can accomplish and the results that we
deliver let me ask everyone in the room
we have a room full of congressmen and
women is everybody on the same page with
the commitments to America everybody
is there anybody
is there anybody and you can be honest
anybody that has disagreements with it
nobody okay what about the
investigations are you on board for all
these investigations
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else